[Musik]
das wäre geschafft das weihnachtsfest
links aus und vor uns liegen mit etwas
glück tage des lesens tatsächlich ist
die zeit zwischen den jahren so viele
eine der besten gelegenheiten zum
abtauchen den bücher die hohe es da das
sofa der sessel wartet schon neue bücher
sind da oder müssen noch ein paar über
von den neuerscheinungen dieses jahres
die wir uns bis zum schluss aufgehoben
haben um das lesen soll es in dieser
episode des bücher podcasts mit uns
gehen wir sind andrea diener und
fridtjof küchemann und wir wollen heute
über die leselust sprechen und darüber
wie man mit ihr lebt man er nachgibt sie
wach hält oder auch sie weitergibt
wie man mit ihr lebt mit ihr macht wenn
man selbst bücher schreibt oder wenn man
literatur unterrichtet weil man als
lehrerin jugendlichen ausschnitte aus
einer welt zeigt in der man sich selbst
so wohlfühlt abschießen liebe hörerinnen
und hörer erwartet sie noch ein gedicht
aus der frankfurter anthologie in dem es
am rande auch ums lesen geht dreifachen
street journal heißt es von georg von
der bringen wir haben uns gäste
eingeladen um mit ihnen über das lesen
zu sprechen beriet glanz ist
schriftstellerin ihr roman pixel tänzer
ist vor zwei jahren erschien und die
februar kommt auch schon das nächste
heraus es wird automatisch heißen oder
auto und bei in berlin verlag verlegt
während glanz ist dazu noch
skandinavistik und wie erreichen sie in
island wo sie inzwischen lebt hall
obilic schön dass du zeit für uns hast
hallo
genau man sagt ich glaube man sagt
automaten aber ich bin mir nicht so
richtig sicher weil ich irgendwie auch
merke ich ja schon irgendwie zwischen
button ports strahlen der von daher
glaube ich beides richtig aber ja das
ist ein problematischer titel was das
betrifft
unser zweiter gastes michael bartel
lehrerin und leserin in hamburg sie
kümmert sich also darum die schülerinnen
und schüler mit literatur in kontakt
kommen und womit sie es im abitur zu tun
bekommen vielen dank dass du dabei bist
die michael bei unserem gespräch ein
schön bei euch nach franken und islam
tage des lesens heißt auch ein essay von
marcel proust und noch bevor der
verfasser zu erkenntnissen kommt wie der
es gehört zu den großen und wunderbaren
eigenschaften für bücher dass sie für
den autor schlussfolgerungen für den
leser jedoch anreize heißen können noch
davor beschreibt er einen typischen tag
des lesens in seiner kindheit eigentlich
beschreibt er eine abfolge von störungen
unterbrechungen gefährdungen des lesens
eine taste frage werde also vielleicht
so was wie wo und wie findet ihr die
ruhe zum lesen welche ruhe und welchen
schutz braucht euer lesen überhaupt
also ich lese tatsächlich morges und 5
ich habe irgendwie festgestellt dass das
die ruhigste zeit überhaupt des tages
ist weil niemand anruft eine e mail
schreibt oder ein frühstück braucht oder
so
und das ist für mich eine ganz
genussvolle zeit um ganz in ruhe
zu lesen
ich würde sofort so jeden morgen wenn
dann um 5 der wecker klingelt im schlaf
wird durch müssen vorangehen vom lesen
muss ich eingestehen ich auch gleich
[Musik]
aus der reha klinik nicht damit
herrschen also ich mache tatsächlich
einfach auf also
und mittlerweile eine zeit lang hatte
schlafstörungen und dann habe ich
gedacht das ist doch endlich
letztendlich egal wann man schläft und
mittlerweile mache ich so ganz
genussvoll auf und denke super noch zwei
stunden was ich aufstehen muss
und das ist so eine zeit die ich
mittlerweile ist sehr ritualisiert so
für mich nutzen um meinen gedanken
nachzugehen und um zu lesen heißt das
wie ist das denn bei dir berit du hast
ja durchaus eine größere familie mit
kindern die durch die gegend toben wo
findest du deine ruhe
also ich erkläre ja mal dass sich die
meisten büchern die ich lese im jahr auf
meinem handy leser also als e-books an
das finden die leute immer ganz komisch
das ist aber ganz pragmatisch weil ich
eben drei kinder habe ist es 60 das hat
irgendwann angefangen hat sie sehr klein
war dass ich diesen moment hat man dann
abends neben dem bett saß und dann
wartet dass die rheinschiffer wurde
immer wütender mann konnte aber selber
kein licht anmachen weil dann schießen
sie ja nicht und habe irgendwann
angefangen beim handy zu lesen also
kindle ebooks und das hat sich irgendwie
so festgesetzt lesen mit meinem mit
meinem handy was passt tatsächlich also
es gibt gar nicht so richtig feste
zeiten aus so dass sich halt immer
versuche vom einschlafen ganz viel noch
mal runter zu lesen oder ein paar seiten
zu schaffen auf jeden fall genau
runter lesen hört sich jetzt nicht so
rasend nach genuss an ist es aber doch
doch ich werde doch tatsächlich versucht
tatsächlich vorm schlafen immer nur
bücher zu leben die ich wirklich auch
lesen will das ist ja dieses
glück und leid gleichzeitig will man
professionell ließ dass man eben super
viele bücher lesen muss oder diesen will
dann hat er nicht auch aber dass das
sich dann so vermischt mitarbeiters
bedeutet ich versuche tatsächlich abend
also ab einer bestimmten uhrzeit nur
noch texte zu lesen wo ich irgendwie
nicht denke ach da können sie mal was
drüber schreiben oder dass es hier
besonders gut gelöst vielleicht sollte
ich das auch so machen oder so sondern
wirklich nur aus freude
das heißt es gibt eine
lesezeit die reserviert ist für
professionelles lesen es gibt eine
lesezeit die reserviert ist für das
private oder das genuss lesen das kann
sich natürlich mischen aber
grundsätzlich versuchst du da versucht
wahrscheinlich ihr ich nehme an dass mit
dem ich anders gehen michael das
voneinander zu trennen
ich denke also ich glaube ich trenne das
nicht willst du gar nicht wie ich das
trennen sollte ehrlich gesagt also es
gibt natürlich irgendwie so
dass ich das was in richtung redigieren
geht oder
text nochmal lesen den ich irgendwie für
eine prüfung vorbereitet oder so wo ich
dann was sehr spezielles suche aber
ich glaube nicht dass ich das so trenne
weil
flächen ist das auch so eine
professionelle die formation also ich
alles was ich lese denke ich immer
sofort könnte ich das machen im
unterricht was könnte damit
funktionieren und ich lese auch
eigentlich immer gern mit bleistift aus
dem grund also um
so was was festhalten zu können oder und
gleichzeitig gebe es da eine enge
büchereien
ich schreibe sehr gerne mittlerweile
vorne auf das statement also wenn ich
jetzt irgendwas lese im buch was mich
was ich so mitnehmen möchte dann
schreibe ich das vorne auf die dieser
meistens leer die erste seite also wohl
nur der der titel steht und das schreibe
ich das dann hin und das vereinfachte
ist für mich sehr sachen wiederzufinden
ich habe auch meine ecken lag aber das
so hießen knicken ist es ist richtiger
eingriff mehr dass er das wo ich bin ich
bin sehr frei mit büchern reinschreiben
und server ecken können sich auch
irgendwie fühlt sich immer sehr
gewaltvoll an bei mir war das natürlich
ganz gut ich war lange es kann ihn und
war lange hauptberuflich skandinavistik
und konnte natürlich immer sagen
skandinavische bücher lese ich nicht in
den abendstunden weil dann denke ich
immer was ich damit machen kann das hat
sich jetzt natürlich irgendwie auch so
ein bisschen gegeben und dann
überschneidet sich das natürlich dann
ist mein buch und denke das passt
natürlich perfekt dazu aber es gibt ja
irgendwie so bis auf die man wirklich
richtig lust hat die man unbedingt lesen
möchte und wo dieser die freude an dem
buch über weg dass man darüber nachdenkt
was man jetzt wie man es einsatz zu
können - 8 für mich so
was war zuletzt zum beispiel ein buch
bei dem ist hier so gegangen ist
ein buch was ich so angefangen habe
allerdings mir dann aber gar nicht zu
also als sie aus dieser freude angesagt
so gut gefällt mir gar nicht es gibt
tatsächlich ja jetzt gerade diesen ganz
heftigen trend dass autorin so mühten
neu erzählen ich glaube es hat mit
diesem matellia bestseller zetsche
angefangen aber das gibt es jetzt
irgendwie durch alle bandbreiten also
alle hat mir ganz viel griechisch und es
gibt eben auch ein der
wo nordische mythologie verhandelt wird
das kam jetzt in diesem jahr ich glaube
es heißt jetzt heißt which is halt das
habe ich angefangen weil ich dachte dass
das irgendwie toll da ist ein deutscher
mit logi was mich natürlich fach bedingt
wahnsinnig interessiert findet dieses
mit neu erzählt spannend aber ich war
dann gar nicht so begeistert beim lesen
aber da war wirklich diese diese lust am
sohn an einer fiktion die die spannend
ist wo irgendwie ja es ist natürlich bei
diesen mythen nacherzählung auch
irgendwie einfach nur weil das ist halt
so wahnsinnig viel geschichte in diesen
büchern aber wir waren gar nicht so toll
tatsächlich
mich würde interessieren liest ihr immer
ein buch oder habt ihr mehrere bücher
die er parallel lässt also wenn ich
jetzt ganz ehrlich sein soll ich lese
zwar parallel aber ehrlich gesagt die
die ich weg lege um sie dann irgendwie
weiter zu lesen weil mir was anderes
dazwischen kommt lese ich dann meistens
echt nicht fertig ich lese tatsächlich
echt viel parallel aber ich kenne das
auch das manchmal dieses dass man ein
anderes buch anfängt auch ein zeichen
dafür ist dass das buch irgendwie verein
selber nicht so gebracht hat und ich
meine ich lese ich lese viel sagt mich
ja auch und da ist es ja ganz gut dass
man zwischendurch immer mal unterbrechen
kann also wenn die dann besonders eine
gute kapitalstruktur dann hat man mal
auf und macht das anders weiter und so
doch ich würde sagen ich habe eine ganze
reihe von büchern die irgendwie parallel
in betrieb sind wo die frage ist auch
diesmal noch ein buch was man nicht
fertig gelesen hat was aber dennoch
liegt und einen schuldgefühle macht ist
es noch ein bild das man dienst oder ist
da gibt es
die seit einem dreivierteljahr
dieses buch von michael maar über dienst
die das hab ich zu dem viertel
angefangen ich fand es fantastisch und
dann wurde es irgendwie so zugeschüttet
durch aber jetzt liest man schnell dass
und diesmal schnell die so weiter und
ich habe die ruhe nicht gefunden das
lange das zu ende zu lesen das ist
glaube ich wirklich ein buch für die
ruhe
und das ist keine die schlange im
wolfspelz heißt es die schlange
es ging mir exakt genauso mit genau die
mit genau dem buch und mit genau dem ich
es ist total toll ich will unbedingt
weiter lesen aber ich muss noch das und
ich muss noch das und ich muss noch das
also so gesehen gibt es bei mir sowieso
also mehrere bücher die ich gleichzeitig
leser es gibt bücher die bei mir auf dem
schreibtisch landen mit der bitte dazu
eine besprechung zu schreiben die ich
mir nicht ausgesucht hat dann gibt es
die die ich mir ausgesucht habe
die haben so ein unterschiedliches
unterschiedlichen druck sozusagen oder
eine unterschiedliche zug druck balance
und dann gibt es bücher die ganz gut so
wenn ich vorm einschlafen noch drei vier
seiten lesen will aber weiß dass es mehr
eben auch nicht werden weil die schon
einigermaßen müde bin
also eher so ein
bedarf des genuss lesen und dann gibt es
auch wirklich die leser nachmittag
lesebücher wo ich weiß wenn ich mich da
jetzt rein crew dann würde ich da auch
bitte erstmal ein paar stunden drin sein
in diesem buch die gibt es auch noch die
freue ich mich jetzt für die nächsten
tage ganz besonders sind das dann auch
so so die gegen klassiker bei dir
ja ja ich hatte mir eigentlich ein
dostojewski und vorgenommen jetzt für
die für die zeit und dann ist mir also
was dazwischengekommen klingt irgendwie
so seltsam es gibt jetzt diese davon
hatten wir es auch vor ein paar wochen
im tücher podcast die erste
weitestgehend zensur freie übersetzung
oder übersetzung der weitest des
weitestgehend zensur freien originals
von stalingrad wassili grossman der
human und mir ist ein großonkel dort
geblieben und das ist irgendwie ein
thema was so familie doch eine rolle
gespielt hat bei uns und jetzt einen
[Musik]
sowjetrussischen schriftsteller darüber
erzählen zu wissen das ist eine sache
die mich beschäftigt und ich glaube also
es ist ein klassiker was gleichzeitig
auch was das ist in dieser
vollständigkeit mit 1200 seiten oder so
was bei uns noch nicht gegeben hat das
vor kurzem
und ich glaube das wird ganz sicher bin
ich mir noch nicht also letzten endes
das sitze ich dann da oder die dann da
so halb auf meinem sofa und dann kommt
drauf an welches aus diesem bücherstapel
ich als erstes raus sie aber auch das
gefühl werdet ihr erkennen ja ich finde
also ich fühle mich so ein bisschen
christian wieso ich immer bewiesen so
kritikwürdig sagen ich finde es
eigentlich ganz toll dass da mehrere
bücher liegen die so
dabei sind und ich finde das eigentlich
auch ganz lustvoll dann zu überlegen wo
mache ich dann geht es weiter
ich kenne das auch das weg legen und
dann ist es weg
aber auch das wieder zugreifen und
denken genau jetzt jetzt geht's hier
weiter jetzt bin ich bei diesem buch
dabei
lässt sich das irgendwie also kannst du
irgendwie genauer beschreiben welche
verschiedenen büchern oder gerade am
start ist also es ist
ein klassiker was aktuell ist oder ist
es was was du schon länger lesen wollt
dann kommt aber was dazwischen was dir
gerade neu über den weg gelaufen ist
oder wie sortiert sich so der bücher
stapeln und gleichzeitig im betreff hast
ich
hab mir auch dass sie jetzt vorgenommen
weil irgendwie die dunkle jahreszeit ist
für mich so dass du jetzt gelesen und
ich habe gedacht ich und letztendlich
auch den idioten mal in der neuen
übersetzung also dies ja schon lange
gibt aber die ich nie gelesen habe und
ich lese gerade sascha marianna salzmann
die mich grad sehr interessiert und dann
gibt es so beruflich so kleinere sachen
die dazu kommen also kleinere heiß jetzt
nochmal kleist weil ich mich gerade
damit beschäftigen muss und das ist dann
auch
das mag ich dann auch dann so hierhin
und dahin zu diesen also ich muss den
punkt lesen und fließt dann einfach noch
mal briefe und kürzere texte
und das sind ja sehr unterschiedliche
wie soll ich sagen sehr sehr
unterschiedliche stimmungen die man da
versetzt wird und in dem man befindet
und eigentlich mag ich das gerne da hab
ich noch ein kleines buch versteckt wo
ich immer so kleine texte gerade
zwischendurch lese
und ich lese eigentlich immer das büro
das büro ist auch jetzt meine unter
steht mein handy gerade drauf weil das
so schön im stapel ergibt das ist etwas
sehr beruhigendes für mich das ist dass
die diese diese diese dicke werks
ausgabe im verbrecher verlag von ja
genau das ist ja ja ja ich lese schon
seit jahren also das ist ja insgesamt
ziemlich umfangreich und das ist so für
mich ein text der mich sehr für ruhe
bringt und wo es auch ein gutes gefühl
ist dass ich immer noch drei bände vor
mir also ich lese über die tage nach
weihnachten
irgendwie dann immer so richtig fiktion
oder
meditative sachbuch ich habe einst jetzt
auch das freue ich mich dass will ich
unbedingt lesen das heißt garde ring
muss das kommt glaube ich im frühjahr
bei matthes & seitz in den natur- kunden
unter dem titel das sammeln von moos
oder so also geht's los da habe ich eben
das gefühl es passt gut für so ein
jahresende dass man darüber nachdenkt
ist dann so meditativ und schön und
ansonsten ist es bei mir immer also
fiktionen und zwar so doll und
spannungsgeladen und platt geladen und
in anderen welten wie möglich zwischen
diesen zwischen diesen tagen wenn das
jahr endet dann würde ich kein realismus
lesen und auch gerne nichts
so zeigt diagnostisch ist also ich meine
das ist natürlich jeder roman
diagnostiziert die zeit in der entsteht
aber eben auf die die verbindung nicht
ganz so direkt für mich in der zeit
ist das dann so eine sonne guilty
pleasure angelegenheit für dich auch
also den die idee sich also wieso jetzt
witzigerweise ist ein pandemie ja total
extrem weil ich irgendwie das gefühl
habe mein kopf kann nichts außer
geschichten die ich schon keinen festen
wie sie ausgehen ja das ist dass es dann
also nicht gegen flash an dem sinne
sondern schon als ich für das helle nur
häme oder so das ist ja nicht unbedingt
geht die preise oder naomi musik oder so
also dass man halt
wirklich eben fiktion und kein realismus
gerne
mythen nach erzählungen so war es eher
oder auch ja irgendwie gutes high
fantasy oder scifi oder magischer
realismus auch total gerne liebe ich
nach weihnachten solche bücher also wo
ich das gefühl hat irgendwie die welt
wie sie es wird aufgebrochen und
realismus dann am liebsten gar nicht
oder hat er auch seine zeit ostern zum
beispiel
realismus sagen achtung würden finde es
richtig
realismus lief ich hab auch ganz gerne
es ja ganz viel realistischer
gegenwartsliteratur
aber ich habe immer das gefühl irgendwie
weil man so wenn man so runter fährt
dann ist dann ja das kann kann auch
wirklich jetzt an diesem letzten zwei
jahren liegen aber es hat mich jetzt
letzten zwei jahre über die
weihnachtstage begleitet dass ich ganz
wenig
realistische literatur gelesen habt
vielleicht ändert sich das auch mal
wieder aber ich lese auch nicht an
ostern den realismus oder pfingsten
einfach nur in diesen tagen er nicht
gerne
ja ich finde das eine interessante frage
ob die pandemie euer leseverhalten
irgendwie verändert hat also bei mir
sicherlich dadurch dass ich natürlich
jetzt irgendwie diesen extrem
homeschooling tun hat von mehreren
monaten und dann mit drei kindern dass
ich also auf der einen seite angefangen
habe ich lese wieder mehr lyrik was
irgendwie schön ist weil das einfach in
die zeitfenster mehr rein passt was
immer lörick gelesen aber jetzt wirklich
gezielt weil ich das gefühl habe ich
habe das gelesen was mir irgendwie was
gegeben hat aber gleichzeitig ist auch
okay wenn ich nach fünf minuten
unterbrochen werden
dass mir als ich lese mir lyrik und ich
hatte eben eine ganz extreme hase in
diesem jahr durch das gefühl hatte ich
kann kaum
zeit diagnostisches ist sehr
problematisches auch trauriges
zusätzlich noch aushalten sondern ich
brauch tatsächlich die geschichten nicht
erwiesen war mit decke um einen herum
legen also wahrscheinlich habe ich
deswegen dieses jahr eben auch so viele
von diesen mythen riet allerdings
irgendwie gelesen weil es einfach man
kennt ja die geschichte also mit weiß
was bei uns passiert oder bei ariadna
aber sozusagen das dann einfach noch mal
neu erzählt bekommen war wahnsinnig
angenehm irgendwie ja ich weiß gar nicht
ob ich wirklich anders gelesen haben
also wenn wir das auch so dass ich die
zeitweise mit drei kindern hier alleine
im homeschooling war das hat natürlich
die zeit sinniert aber andererseits bin
ich auch nicht weggegangen also war man
abends dann auch viel da und
ich war zweimal in quarantäne und das
war schon sehr speziell also da habe ich
mich auch da habe ich gemerkt ich muss
mich irgendwie in literatur vertiefen um
das für mich so balancieren aber ich
ließ dann tatsächlich
wenn ich so das gefühl ab ich werde so
ein bisschen labil quasi dann lese ich
gerne
sachen wo es sehr düster ist aber dann
muss das sozusagen dunkler in der
literatur sein als in mir und dann
ist das natürlich wahnsinnig spannend
weil ich glaube dass es bei mir wirklich
exakt andersherum
das macht mir richtig für mich ist das
eher so wie weißt du wenn man so ganz
wenn man sich ganz schlecht fühlt und
dann scheint die sonne und alle sagen
ist doch super das wetter und ich denke
an wie bei irgendwie bin ich gerade aber
gar nicht ganz fröhlich und es ist
irgendwie so negativ ausgleich also ich
kann dann lieber noch mal was ich nicht
bernhard das so jeske oder so
gute hasser lesen und dann
danach
hatte
ich ein ganz gutes labeln sondern auch
thema vertraut
bei mir ist das dann so meditativ ich
ich legt er wirklich momentan viel von
diesen die pilze das mikro bio um das
muss also diese diesen diesen sachen
trend der irgendwie so mikroskop auf die
natur gelegt und ich glaube das ist
schon auch so ein
pandemie phänomen tatsächlich das
irgendwie dass ich sehr schön anfühlt
und meditativen text über die kreation
also die natur kunden sind bei mir ganz
groß gewesen mir hat mal eine erzählt ja
bei einem großen beider ketten
buchhandlungen arbeitet sozusagen der
großen buchhändler in diesem land und er
sagte das wichtigste ist dass also für
ein buch das beste was mir passieren
kann ist dass bei uns auf einen der
beiden großen tische kommt vorne gleich
am eingang und diese beiden tische die
haben namen wie sehr gerade mit diesem
gute hast daran denken der eine heißt
große gefühle da würde hassen vielleicht
ja sogar noch mit dazu passt anreist
schwäche frauen und dachte gerade ob die
das nicht irgendwie so richtig falsch
machen bei diesen buchladen ob die nicht
anders heißen fristen diese diese diese
tische und ob gute hast ja nicht erkannt
hast dich name sind für so ein tisch
wäre so oder so satirisch
für die bücher bei dem protagonist noch
schier
sozusagen euch hin träumen können den
gibt's einen besser als ausreichend
schöne menschen
es ist der fleisch tisch praktisch
ja sehr schön
was mich ja immer so ein bisschen was
ich aber total interessant finde es
woher leute eigentlich ihre lektüre
tipps beziehen also man wünscht sich
natürlich als zeitung dass sie das aus
der zeitung beziehen aber wir kennen ja
alle in unserer gegenwart das heißt es
schwimmt ein praktisch von überall her
an
die buchhändler freunde oder sogar
dieses internet das soll es auch buch
tipps geben habe ich gehört
oder lektüre podcasts oder ähnliches was
sind denn eure hauptquellen eigentlich
bei mir ist es reicht einfach weil ich
ja eben das hat sich ja wahrscheinlich
jetzt auch in gesprächen so ein bisschen
herauskristallisiert ich habe immer so
leitmotive oder so themenstränge die
mich dann für ein paar monate ganz
intensiv interessieren
und dann kann man ja immer von a nach b
nach c hüpfen also wenn ich jetzt sage
mich interessiert muss das natürlich
auch mal gegen mich interessiert pilze
oder so dann geht es immer von einem zum
nächsten
ansonsten ist es bei mir tatsächlich
viel social media aber ich lese
tatsächlich auch und das ist natürlich
irgendwie auch wahrscheinlich eine
professionelle die formation nicht ließ
tatsächlich die verlagsprogramme und
denke auch das könnte mich interessiert
dann vergesse nichts wieder aber dann
trifft treffe ich irgendwo dann den
namen wieder ob es eine zeitung ist oder
das internet und dann denke ich oh ja
das wollte ich noch und dann und das ist
bei mir auch tatsächlich gewesen dieses
jahr der der newsletter von magdeburg
man weil die auch runde thematischen
rahmen hat und manchmal passten die dann
perfekt zu dem was mich auch gerade
interessiert und dann ist es natürlich
wie eine goldgrube weil dann kommen eben
sechs bücher zu einem thema was zu
meiner art zu lesen ganz gepasst
so
mag dann schon aus
da wird man ist ihres zeichens
buchhändlerin im ozelot in berlin eine
freundin von uns
genau abonniert ihren newsletter ist
wirklich thematisch sehr schön sortiert
und eine fundgrube abseitiger liegt ihr
tipps es war wie ist es bei dir marke
also ich lese schon zeitung und führt
traum muss ich fragen ich lese
fasziniert immer die longlist
also da gibt es immer dieses kleine
bändchen und ich versuche immer
also mehrere titel davon dann auch ganz
zu leben aber die weil ich so gerne ich
suche letztendlich immer lektüren die
man auch in der schule lesen kann und
wie man vorschlagen kann für solche
themen schwerpunkte und deswegen weiß
ich irgendwie so ganz gerne was es
was so da ist was besprochen wird und
der rest
als ich nicht kommen durch verschiedene
durch durch freunde durch die
buchhändlerin kann ich gar nicht so
ich gehe da nicht so gezielt glaube ich
los und suche bücher sondern die kommen
so daher und ja
ich finde das ganz interessant dass die
die
nominierungslisten von preisen
tatsächlich einen dann oft auch noch mal
irgendwie auf irgendwelche bücher
schubsen also das würde ich sagen ist
beim wenn ich deutschsprachige
gegenwartsliteratur anschaut bei mir
tatsächlich auch ein faktor aber ich
lese tatsächlich relativ viel
englischsprachig gerade und das ist dann
meistens tatsächlich war irgendwie
medienbeiträge in den entsprechenden us
amerikanischen zeitungen und bei den
isländischen büchern es ist so einfach
weil das sind halt einfach nicht so
wahnsinnig viel da weiß man einfach
dieses regal arbeite ich jetzt abnehmen
so
island ist ja auch einfach ein sehr sehr
kleines land
ja aber hier gibt es ja die weihnachts
bücher flut die diese jolo kampflos das
kommt immer im dezember wird es dann in
den medien irgendwie thematisierten
deutschsprachigen habe ich das gefühl
als weil hier die bücher vor weihnachten
veröffentlicht werden also da kommt
sozusagen ganz viele neuerscheinungen
auf einmal und dann ist wirklich auch in
den supermärkten wird dann im regal
platz freigeräumt und es stehen dann
halt bücher und das ist irgendwie ganz
plötzlich also dann kommt man kann den
büchern auch hier in der
vorweihnachtszeit quasi ganz entkommen
wenn man das möchte sondern deswegen man
verschenkt eben auch standardmäßig
bücher was steht da sonst den rest des
jahres über in diesem regal in dem dann
bücher stehen
also da wo jetzt frei geräumten sind
sonst immer socken und schreibwaren denn
in dem supermarkt wo ich bin da ist
jetzt sozusagen jetzt drei große regale
mit büchern die den ganzen platz 1 der
braucht im winter auch socken die sind
jetzt gegen geld angegangen mitte
gewandert vermutlich ist irgendwo anders
was weggenommen worden ich habe die die
architektur nicht komplett verstanden
aber es ist sozusagen es wird wirklich
es werden wirklich regalmeter geschaffen
für ebendiese weihnachts bücher flut das
ist nicht
partizipieren ihr dann als als deutsch
isländische familie da auch fuld rand
also nehmt ihr das total mit die
weihnachts bücher flut ja weil das ja
eben das motto geschenkt ist für den
erweiterten familienkreis ist man
schenkt sich tatsächlich bücher das
bedeutet man man kriegt dann auch an
weihnachten einfach viele bücher und ich
finde das tatsächlich auch ein ganz
gutes geschenke sind bücher deutlich
teurer als in deutschland
klar weil die an viel geringerer auflage
produziert werden aber dieses dass man
einfach weiß an weihnachten verschenkt
man sich bücher das macht es ja auch so
ein bisschen einfacher also man muss
dann eben nicht in der großen warenwelt
seine bing suchen sondern man weiß eben
es gibt diese bücher und davon würden
einige kriegen
das hin traummann muss und ein einziges
geschäft gehen sozusagen für die
weihnachtseinkäufe
und kann gleich mit dem café mit mir und
jedes tor
hat sich hat sich für euch das
buch als weihnachtsgeschenk eigentlich
so in den
jahrzehnten die es uns alle jetzt schon
gibt verändert also ist das ist das ein
hat es als geschenk an bedeutung
gewonnen oder verloren oder als art des
schenkens
sie sich verändert wir es irgendwann
klar geworden dass ist ein paar jahre
her natürlich jetzt auch schon wieder
dass ich gedacht habe man verschenkt er
nicht nur etwas was einem selbst am
herzen liegt bestenfalls oder was ich
mir wünschen dass es mal ausgeschlossen
aber wenn man etwas verschenkt wenn ich
ein buch verschenken von dem ich mir
erhoffe dass der beschenkte die
beschenkte das auch mag dann verschenke
ich ja gleichzeitig die erwartung dass
da jemand acht stunden lebenszeit für
dran gibt und das war irgendwie mir wenn
du diese 1200 seiten
das ist in der geschenk tätigkeit glaube
ich nicht
man darf nur bücher verschenken die
unter 500 seiten sind dann das okay für
die zeit die man dann investieren muss
ich finde also ich geschenkt tatsächlich
mehr bücher habe ich das gefühl in den
letzten jahren weil ich auch irgendwie
das ganze jahr über bücher finde wo ich
dann manchmal denke das passt gut zu der
person aber da macht es auch nichts aus
wenn die beschenkte person die dann gar
nicht liest also ich meine das ist ja
eben meine eigene entscheidung aber ich
freue mich auch weiterhin immer über
bücher also schöne geschenke toll
ja ich freue mich auch weiterhin noch
über bücher
aber das wird weniger habe ich das
gefühl dass mir bücher geschenkt werden
also eher so zwischendurch im jahr also
dass man über das geredet hat und dann
jemand ein buch dazu schickt macht im
gespräch aber an den an weihnachten an
geburtstagen war das glaube ich früher
mehr habe ich das gefühl dass ich bücher
geschenkt bekommen habe
und ich bin da aber auch hemmungslos
also wenn ich denke das ist irgendwie
tolles buch ist dass mir zu der person
einfällt oder dass ich mich über das ich
gerne rhin wollen würde mit der person
dann mache ich das auch
auf 1200 ehrlich gesagt ich bin so
erleichtert
eine kleine dicke schinken geschenke
etikett das ist eigentlich ein ganz
guter zungen bereich
[Musik]
aber ich finde es wird tatsächlich auch
schwieriger weil die leute dann doch
irgendwie immer mehr lesen sie werden
älter sind lesen immer mehr sie haben
immer mehr gelesen und es wird immer
komplexer noch was zu finden wo man
genau weiß sie lernen sie noch nicht
und ich habe dann auch wirklich
zunehmend angst wenn leute mir bücher
schenken also wenn das wirklich
qualifizierte bücher schenker sind sie
sich damit befasst haben freut mich das
total und da ist dann die chance auch
groß aber
jetzt irgendwelche random bekannte wenn
die mir bücher schenken dann habe ich
immer ein bisschen angst ehrlich gesagt
so was was ist da jetzt drin ist das
jetzt nicht doch irgendwie so
ja irgendwie wird ja auch die nische die
man dann mag am ende wird auch immer ein
bisschen kleiner
also ich habe auch immer mehr bei gefühl
was bieten sie immer mehr je mehr ich
lese dass du mir habe ich auch das
gefühl so kenne ich schon das ist das
wieder so acht schon wieder so eine
coming-of-age-geschichte von
irgendwelchen reichen jungs aus der
deutschen mittelschicht also man hakt
irgendwie immer mehr für sich ab so ein
bisschen und die chance dass man mir
sowas schenk wo ich denke so
nicht schon wieder steigt natürlich auch
immens wie ist das mit lyrik also ich
habe das gefühl ich kann man einmal gut
verschenken weil da investiert man nicht
unendlich viel zeit rein man kriegt man
guten mann man kriegt einen guten
eindruck auch wenn man wenige texte
gelesen hat aus dem buch man kann auch
das nur teilweise rezipieren und
gleichzeitig gibt es da ja irgendwie so
viel und leute kaufen des jahrgangs zu
viel dann erwischt man eigentlich immer
bücher die noch nicht im regal stehen
habe ich das gefühl das stimmt das
eigentlich ziemlich sichere bank weil
ich kenne mich damit auch nicht genug
aus um ehrlich zu sein und wenn man mir
lyrik schenkt und wenn das menschen tun
von denen ich denke die wissen was sie
da schenken dann immer her damit was
qualifiziert einen qualifizierten bücher
schenker
das habe ich ja auch geplant das wollte
sie auch hören
[Musik]
ja vielleicht doch die leute die so ein
bisschen mehr lesen als die top five der
spiegel-bestsellerliste vielleicht
wo ich auch das gefühl habe die
erwischen vielleicht geheimtipps die ich
noch nicht kenne und
die auch so ein bisschen abseits der
pfade lesen und dinge kennen die ich die
mir noch nie begegnet sind und so
und einen eigenen gefestigten geschmack
haben vielleicht kann man es so
ausdrücken
also wichtig ist glaube ich beim bücher
geschenken vor allem oder hält nicht
wichtig ist vor allem dass man
wenn man bücher verschenkt das nicht mit
einem erziehungs anspruch tut also dass
man sozusagen gegen buch geschmack der
person die man beschenkt einfach
akzeptiert und nicht versucht sie zu
bilden oder einen besseren geschmack
oder so zu machen oder wenn jemand eben
besonders gerne thriller liest dann muss
man sich da eben drauf einlassen so ich
denke das ist der trick aber
das funktioniert auch nicht also ich
kann doch nicht also wenn ich zur schule
lesen überhaupt keine rolle das ja doch
irgendwie ein tolles geschenk wenn ich
das jetzt jemand schenken würde es kann
er sich doch dann selber kaufen das aber
da gibt es doch so viel wo man irgendwie
nachricht erzählen kann was toll ist und
dann irgendwas abseitiges finden kann
mir leuchtet das nicht nicht ein wie
also vielleicht bin ich da auch
altmodisch aber ich finde so ein
geschenk soll ja irgendwas sein also
jetzt meine ich nicht ich verschenke
jetzt irgendwie jeder muss jetzt den
voßkuhle dafür nur weil ich den leser
das weiß ich dass das ein wirklich
merkwürdiges
eine merkwürdige freude ist sich an
diesem buch an diesem büro habe aber
irgendwie ist das doch schon bücher
schenken ist doch auch in dem man die
alu oder nicht also
man schenkt auch was von sich selbst mal
genau anschaut doch was man sich selbst
man möchte doch irgendwie
sagen guck mal so so sieht die welt auch
aus oder so sehe ich auch aus oder das
was sie dem rat an guckst das kann eine
brücke sein zwischen uns oder so
also das ist doch eigentlich die gäste
also das wäre dann auch die sozusagen
der der abgleich mit dem niemanden
belehren wollen niemanden erziehen
wollen mit einem buchgeschenk oder so
was also dass man
gleichzeitig die man was schenkt
das am selbst was bedeuteten von dem man
sich auch was verspricht beim anderen ja
funktioniert aber vor allem bei
gleichaltrigen oder wie jetzt dann
nämlich vermutlich bei der frage wären
wie ist das mit schüler ja ich würde das
schon oft schon kommen die frage ja
das interessiert uns allen
das ist natürlich prinzipiell anders
weil ich jetzt nicht sagen würde man
literatur unterricht ist ein geschenk
für die schülerinnen und schüler
sondern das ist ja irgendwie
wechselseitiger job so aber eine
einladung sollte ist natürlich schon
sein finde ich egal ob ich mir den text
jetzt selber ausgesucht habe den ich da
unterrichte oder nicht
hoffe ich natürlich auch dass das der
anfang eines gesprächs ist und ich hoffe
natürlich auch dass die da vom platz
gehen mit dem gefühl
jetzt habe ich irgendwas gesehen
wahrgenommen was ich vorher nicht
gesehen oder wahre nummer also warum
finde ich geht es doch auch um darunter
würde ich jetzt auch ungern machen wenn
ich ganz ehrlich bin also im unterricht
auf jeden fall aber ich finde bye bye
bye buch geschenken für für jugendliche
oder für kinder geht schon echt auch
darum zu schauen was wollen die lesen
und wenn das dann eben die minecraft
paletten romane sind dann sind das die
manche humana und so also
weil da habe ich das gefühl dass da oft
der pädagogische gehst du sehr
durchbricht bei den menschen also soll
daneben schwab die griechische ich weiß
ganz viele titel genommen ist also nur
der der bildungsanspruch kommt dann ganz
plötzlich und die freude nicht also dass
das eben einfach toll ist und spaß macht
die geht dann irgendwie hintergrund da
bin ich total mit ihren also mein sohn
hat zum beispiel dieses die polanski
bücher gelesen ich darauf alle und ich
kann das auch wenn ich das jetzt in den
für die texte nicht teilen kann kann ich
ja dieses sich irgendwie sonne so eine
reine verliehen das kann ich total
verstehen und das ist ja auch ein
schönes und ganz so magisches legen als
als als jugendliche also ähnlich auch
noch selber dass man ihn so in serien zu
verloren gehen kann und so fuhr ich bin
wirklich auch auf das nächste buch
wartet und so dass es irgendwie so eine
erfahrung die glaube ich zur synthese
sozialisation auch wirklich dazu gehört
weil das so eine ganz elementare freude
ist irgendwie am lesen selber genau das
glück wenn man feststellt dass es noch
ganz viele andere davon gibt also ganz
viele andere bücher
genau wie man oder man verliert sich
plötzlich ein neues genre was man
kennenlernt merkt mensch also thriller
das ist total oder liebesroman und es
gibt unendlich
kandidaten lesen das ist natürlich
irgendwie ganz großartig ja ich würde
gerne nochmal auf dieses darunter tut es
auch nicht nur darunter wäre es das für
mich auch nicht so kommen dass du gesagt
hat ist maike
also mir ging es damals so im
deutschunterricht dass ich mein lesen
irgendwie auch vor
den kommentaren desinteressiert
mitschülerinnen und mitschüler
mitschüler hauptsächlich schützen wollte
also dass ich eher
so dass es mir schwer fiel
ihnen zu unterstellen oder von ihnen
anzunehmen
dass sie alle was davon haben könnten
und haben wollten überhaupt haben und
ich glaube das ist ein hoher anspruch
mit dem du in dein deutsch unterricht
dann rein gehst und
lässt sich der also jagd da offenbar
lässt sich der aufrechterhalten die
staunen über ihnen gerade fertig
also es gibt ja unterschiedliche arten
zu lesen und über literatur zu sprechen
und ich glaube auch dass es wichtig ist
dass man
so mögliche wege eröffnet im
deutschunterricht letztendlich also
diese was wir alle noch im kopf haben
dass man an so keck stellen so rumpf
riemelt und so und dann
das ist ja auch anstrengend das auch
nicht immer schön aber es ist natürlich
bestimmte texte auch wichtig um
weiterzukommen glaube ich um dinge zu
verstehen die sich nicht beim ersten
lesen erschließen und das ist nun
gelesen
dass man vielleicht auch lernen muss
also was nicht von vornherein da ist
und gleichzeitig
glaube ich auch wenn beim niesen gelingt
dann bleibt es eben auch was
persönliches also etwas was mir das
gesagt hat womit ich etwas anfangen
konnte
warum auch immer und das kann man auch
nicht
immer ausweisen was ist das was das
eigentlich ist und
je länger ich lehrerin bin desto mehr
merke ich das schreiben eine wichtige
sache ist also viele schülerinnen und
schüler schreiben gerne und schreiben
auch gerne über das was sie da erleben
am lesen und das ist dann eben schreiben
dass auch nicht der aufsatz ist oder so
das meine ich das muss man natürlich
auch machen im deutschunterricht aber
nachdenken nachdenkliches schreiben
und wenn ich solche leseprojekt mache in
denen es dafür raum gibt dann kommen da
tatsächlich sehr
interessante sachen bei raus ich glaube
auch für die schülerinnen und schüler
selbst die sie vorher nicht gewusst
haben und dann teilen sie es auch gerne
wieder miteinander
also weil das auch nicht so ein mann
sitzt an diese unterrichtssituation und
jeder muss irgendwie was kluges oder
dumm ist oder versteckt ist oder was
auch immer sagen
sondern man hat dann liegen schon
schreiben nachgedacht und dann kann man
das auch wieder auf eine andere weise
miteinander teilen
ich weiß nicht ob echtes vorstellen kann
er damit etwas anfangen ich stelle mir
das gerade ziemlich intim vor eigentlich
und trotzdem haben sie es gerne
miteinander
einfach wir menschen sind ja verschieden
habe ich machen so ist es den
jugendlichen auch
tatsächlich finde ich dass das
jugendliche
dass die dass die gespräche mit
jugendlichen oft deswegen so toll sind
weil sie
vielleicht offener sind als wir
erwachsene und auch
mehr bereit sind andere perspektive
sich anzuhören und das noch mal so zu
drehen und zu wenden und ich erlebe das
schon dass es oft ein wirkliches
interesse daran gibt sich wenn die frage
irgendwie als wichtig erkannt wird wenn
ich merke dass hatte irgendwas mit mir
zu tun und das jetzt in wien nicht nur
ich sollte jetzt nicht nur herlein was
comedian merkmale sind oder was sie
weimarer klassik ist oder so das ist ja
boring also ich finde es ja an sich
bringt das wird ja erst interessant wenn
man das so verknüpft mit irgendwas was
einem selber beschäftigen könnte
und wenn es so eine frage gibt dann
[Musik]
glaube ich schon also erlebe ich das
schon so dass es eine möglichkeit ist
letztendlich sehr persönliche sachen
auszutauschen sehr persönliche eindrücke
auszutauschen und das ja auch das soll
an literatur ich weiß nicht wie ihr das
so macht aber für mich ist das auch
immer noch mit das tollste an der
literatur dass
es eine möglichkeit ist sich zu
verständigen also das sprechen über
bücher ist eine möglichkeit eine
hochleistungs sprache sozusagen
in dem man solche anspielungen macht
oder den mann sagt ich verstehe die
figur da gerade gar nicht und dann ist
man im gespräch und hinterher weiß man
etwas über werte aber man weiß auch was
über sich selbst im besten fall ich
finde das irgendwie ganz toll weil
janson einer lese sozialisation gibt es
ja mal dieses identifikation lesen wo
man sich selbst ganz stark mit der
hauptfigur oder einer figur
identifizieren kann das sozusagen ganz
es immer irgendwie auf sich bezieht aber
dann ist es ja dieses lesen als
identitäts arbeit was er idealerweise
auch der deutsche gericht anderen ja
auch toll helfen kann dass man eben
merkt es gibt eben ganz viele
verschiedene perspektiven es gibt eben
auch fremd erfahrung mit texten die eben
ganz alt sind und wo eben vollkommen
anderer kontext war und so und das ist
ja dann so ein geschenk wenn man an dem
punkt kommt dass man das eben nicht als
faktenwissen abhakt sondern eben
sozusagen merke ich kann mich immer
wieder zu neuen texten in bezug setzen
und dann fände ich mich und die texte
verändern meinen blick auf die welt
idealerweise und ich kann kann mich
sozusagen darauf einlassen dass manche
texte auch super schwierig sind oder
eigenen dass die
historischen perspektive irgendwie ganz
anders vorkommen ganz fremd vorkommen
das ist eigentlich ganz toll finde ich
ja ich ja ich finde das auch tatsächlich
ich arbeite auch sehr gerne mit ist also
auch mit historischen texten weil die
haben in gewisser weise ja für für meine
schülerin und schüler auch im hohen
aufforderungscharakter in dem die erst
mal total sperrig sind also in ihrer
sprachen sperrig sind in ihrer form
sperrig sind so dass sie das leere und
sagen wir wissen das sind warum warum
soll ich das machen
und es ist natürlich toll wenn man die
erfahrung macht
es passiert tatsächlich was wenn man es
sich genauer anguckt und wenn man sich
darüber austauschen
das eine schöne erfahrung also ich jetzt
jetzt mache ich jetzt nicht nur für mich
ist erin sondern auch für die ist das
ist eine interessante erfahrung dass
dinge verändern sich durch einen anderen
genaueren blick war so
und das gefällt mir tatsächlich an der
arbeit mit klassischen texten oft sehr
gut
und mit
was mit mit texten die man man sagt
immer nur das ist die jetzt der
lebenswelt der schülerinnen und schüler
einspringen was immer das jetzt ist also
weil die sind ja auch nicht alle gleich
da läuft es natürlich er über den plot
das kann man kann man auch machen oder
über die figuren aber
ich finde schon die
die sprache ist auch ein angebot
die eine unterricht ausschließen wollte
dass man diese sich dieser sprache
anwählen kann das heißt wenn du jetzt
deutschunterricht als deinen job und ihr
job als drop der schülerinnen und
schüler dann auch in diesem unterricht
zu sein beschreibt man werde deinen job
dabei
diese texte zu öffnen für
die anderen lachen ja genau ich
weiß jetzt wie ich erwarte hier nicht
dass hinterher alle
nur noch reklame bücher kaufen oder sona
oder überhaupt zu großen leserinnen und
leser werden ich finde
für mich geht es darum genau so die tür
aufzumachen und sagen und wenn ihr durch
gegangen seid dann kann jeder für sich
entscheiden das ist was für mich oder
nicht aber
er ist ja schlecht urteilen und und ich
glaube das ist so für kulturelle
praktiken oder irgendwie sowas gibt wo
man tatsächlich mal mitgenommen sein
muss also so wie in die oper muss man
auch in die literatur einmal mitgenommen
sein und dann weiß man worum es geht und
dann kann man selber weiter suchen oder
die gespräche weiter suchen
oder man nimmt das als so eine episode
was auch ok es also das ist auch in
ordnung das klingt jetzt so einfach wenn
du das erzielt aber also du musst du
weißt dass du hier in dem bücher potters
in dem bücher podcast sprechen dem vor
ein paar monaten mal eine episode sich
um traumatisierende schule hören drehte
und dass
diese einfachheit also
nicht selbstverständlich ist die sable
liest
ich finde das so interessant ich habe ja
viel
durch meinen rat schwerpunkt vaters
gelesen und auch übers unterrichtet und
das sind ja texte diesen dem 1000 jahre
alt und das ist natürlich irgendwie also
ich finde es interessant weil wenn man
über schullektüre spricht das oft
erwartet wird dass es keine reibung gibt
weil ich meine so rische texte sind
schwierig niemand würde von sich
erwarten dass man sich irgendwie kostüm
aus dem rokoko anzieht oder ein korsett
aus dem späten 19 jahrhundert oder so
und das würde nicht sperrig sein und
natürlich steigt man ein in die
gedankenwelt die im historisch irgendwie
weit weg ist und dadurch gibt es dann
diese reibungspunkte ich glaube wenn man
das kommuniziert bekommt dass man nicht
immer alles sofort stehen muss und dass
ich auch vieles fremd anführen kann das
okay ist dass man eben jetzt mal einmal
im historischen kostüm auch zum ball
tanzen geht dann kann man sich da
irgendwie auch darauf einlassen so
vielleicht ja und gleichzeitig diese
historische
distanz ist ja manchmal auch ganz gut um
gespräche zu führen also ich weiß ist
das ja auch leicht touch ihn also wenn
ich jetzt ich unterrichte zum beispiel
gerade den untertanen von heinrich mann
da geht es um autorität und autorität
und gehorsam
dass ihr indien doris gespräch wenn ich
mich dafür meine schülerinnen und
schüler stelle und sage was für
erfahrungen mit autorität habt ihr denn
so gemacht oder wie werdet ihr das aber
wenn man sich anguckt wie ist das
eigentlich vor über 100 jahren das was
nehmen wir da war
das ist ja auch ein gewisser schutz frau
man redet ja nicht direkt über sich
selbst wir alle die nicht direkt über
uns wenn wir über literatur reden
und man kann das aber eben auch so ein
bisschen erproben und das sind wirklich
sehr interessante gespräche und ich
würde auch so ein unterricht über so ein
text nie mit dem text selber anfangen
sondern meist mal gucken was ist das ein
thema worum geht es da und dann guckt
man sich an was passiert in dem buch
ja traumatisierend also mich hat es
tatsächlich eine zeit lang sehr sehr
abgeschreckt ich habe irgendwie so fünf
sechs sieben jahre oder so was private
tatsächlich nur noch sachbücher gelesen
und habe mich für
literatur dann wieder eigentlich sehr
sehr langsam und angetastet
weil das für mich etwas wahr was
also ich starte jetzt nicht gerade aus
einem buch affinen bürgerlichen haushalt
das ist etwas das das gab es halt mehr
oder minder nur in der schule
und dass ich dann irgendwann mal gesagt
habe so ich lese jetzt nach meinem abi
irgendwann mal freiwillig effi briest
und guckt dann doch mal ob es damit was
auf sich hat das hat dann wirklich
einfach noch ein paar jahre gedauert
bei mir hat es ehrlich gesagt doch
relativ viel möglich gemacht und ich
hatte nicht die besten erfahrungen
das ist ein harter befund also ich lasse
meine meine schule und schüler immer so
lesen biografien schreiben und natürlich
riesig dass der release gibt lustvolle
erfahrung mit dem lesen also von solchen
rheins gibt irgendwie das lese in den
ferien und dann kommt immer der satz und
dann kam die schullektüre und dann wird
mir immer in dankersen zunächst ein
schriftliches in der mittelstufe
passiert ist oder welcher texte wie der
absurde für text den sie je gelesen
haben und die gespräche darüber und so
und das natürlich für mich das auch das
wird ja auch schlimm ich mir für meinen
job wenn man sich klar macht dass man
aufpassen muss dass man die leselust
nicht verdirbt also dass man sie nicht
nur nicht befördert sondern dass man sie
zerstört durch das was man da tut aber
da darf dass wir nicht stehen bleiben da
muss es ja etwas geben und ich versuche
auch in meinem job als forscherin
einfach den neuen literatur unterricht
zu bewerben und ich glaube eben dieses
verlockende analysierende lesen das
würde ich jetzt auch nicht aufgeben
wollen weil ich glaube eben so jemand
wie kleist ist ohne das gar nicht zu
haben aber es muss noch andere wege
geben es muss noch andere
andere türen geben und ich glaube dass
das ich das auch wechselseitig dann
sozusagen beleuchtet also wenn man nicht
nur so
mit zum lecks gibt ja diese lektüre
schlüssel nachweisen gebiete die lehrer
haben dann solche lektüre schlüssel und
da die unterrichten das dann so runter
so von a bis z was ist sehr auf der
ersten seite passiert das und dann muss
man auch was will die klassik und so das
ist total tödlich natürlich für
das gespräch über lese erfahrung
genau und deswegen versuche ich das
immer abzuwechseln aber so verschiedene
sequenzen im deutschunterricht mit
literatur denn ich möchte natürlich jede
deutschlehrerin jeder deutschlehrer
möchte dass menschen gerne lesen also ja
auch sonst irgendwie schizophren oder so
wäre ich das nicht wollen würde
aber ich kann nicht kapitulieren und
sagen ja das ist schon
schlimm ja was muss man was machen das
sind den auftrag zum glück war ja auch
die die traumatisierung nicht sonderlich
nachhaltig sie hat ein paar jahre
gehalten und dann waren die bücherei
doch wieder stärker vielleicht hat sich
auf der unterricht
[Musik]
ich glaube dass mir sehr geholfen hat
für freude am lesen tatsächlich das
literaturwissenschaft studium in dem
sinne dass es ein jahr ermächtigt zu
sagen der eigene weg durch den text ist
sozusagen nicht irrelevant und das ist
nicht historische texte sind keine
rätsel spiele wurden die eine richtige
deutung gibt die man verstanden haben
muss und die blaue blume bedeutet immer
dies oder so sondern man kann sich eben
dem text individuell nähern und man kann
daraus zu ziehen was auch was ganz
anderes sein kann als das was sozusagen
so eine historische einordnung lektüre
schlüssel oder so diesem text an
diagnostiziert das fand ich irgendwie
ziemlich befreiend und seitdem habe ich
auch ein lustig eklektizistischen
verhältnis glaube ich zu einfach
historische lektüren also ich mir dann
auch für mich sagen kann dass es gibt
mir jetzt irgendwie gerade nicht aber
das ist irgendwie wieder toll und das
ist so absolut das irgendwie ganz toll
aber ich habe eben nicht mehr diesen
sowie schul- und damit früher war dass
man das gefühl hat es gibt eben eine
richtige deutung und die muss man
irgendwie erlangen und dann hat man das
gut gemacht das lesen und ich glaube da
ist aber auch so viel passiert
mittlerweile das einfach also auch die
lehrer innen sind ja
neue und moderne ausgebildet es kann mir
gar nicht vorstellen dass so was
eigentlich noch passiert nee ich da auch
als ich das du beschreibst du dich sagen
klar darum geht's
genau das auch zu lassen also ich wäre
wer soll ich sein als dass ich weiß wie
man so einen text jetzt richtig
aufschließt und
da passiert dann ja auch nichts also das
ist ja irgendwie auch nicht interessant
also ein solches gespräch ist nicht
interessant im unterricht ich würde
gerne mal zu schauen in seiner sozusagen
das muss ich mir nicht vielleicht mal
irgendwie möglich machen ich würde gerne
mein zustand es zwischendurch nicht
heute so aus ja ich kenne ja quasi nur
die
studierenden die dann kommen aus dem
schul deutschunterricht und da habe ich
das gefühl am 30 einfach riesig was an
vorwissen kommt und an begeisterung und
welche texte gerne gewesen wären
ist herzlich eingeladen
links mal in deutschland bin wirklich
mir mal den unterricht an
[Musik]
schafft es guter deutschunterricht auch
leute fürs lesen zu begeistern die
vorher da noch nicht so dran waren oder
schafft er es eigentlich nur
und auch das ist ja schon viel gewollt
leute
dabei zu halten die das aus der kindheit
mitgebracht haben mir schenkt mir ist
gerade der befund einer lese vorstellung
mit toren vor einiger zeit gesprochen
habe so im kopf wie gesagt hat es bricht
die lesebegeisterung oder die zeit die
jugendlichen mit büchern oder
heranwachsenden mit büchern verbringt
bricht auf ein drittel ein zwischen 14
und sonst war es also und zwar deshalb
weil eben dann
andere arten seine zeit zu verbringen
wichtiger werben andere leute mit
anderen interessen wichtiger werden weil
die eltern als orientierung auch an
bedeutung verlieren können sie noch so
viel lesen selbst wie sie wollen und so
weiter also da gibt es viele faktoren
die dazu führen dass eben daran
tatsächlich so ein leser einbruch
verdientes bestimmte eigenen fachwort
gibt die mir gerade das mir gerade nicht
einfällt das ist dass es diesen einbruch
gibt
gibt es sozusagen erweckungserlebnis
im deutschunterricht also leute die
sagen jetzt also das mit den büchern das
ist echt ne sache und so
ich habe eine ganz tolle veranstaltung
gemacht mit einer kollegin die in
hamburg an der stadtteilschule in
wilhelmsburg glaube ich unterrichtet und
die dort ein leseprojekt gemacht hat mit
ihren schülerinnen und schülern und die
schülerinnen und schüler waren dann mit
in der fortbildung für lehrer innen also
das vorstellt wie macht sie literatur
unterricht oder wir haben gemeinsam
geschäfte machen wenn die tat für
unterricht und sie hat ein paar
schülerinnen und schüler eingeladen und
das waren durchweg
schülerinnen die noch nie zuvor ein buch
gelesen hatten ein ganzes also das war
das buch das sie durch geschafft haben
die waren so 18 würde ich sagen und die
haben davon erzählt
was das was es für ein buch gewesen ist
wie sich das ausgesucht haben wie sie
damit gearbeitet haben und da war das
auf jeden fall so dass diese lehrerin
das geschafft hat
die zu motivieren
das buch durchzulesen und das war bei
den wirklich auch auf der ebene von
riedel diese flüssigkeit also das war
gar nicht es war wirklich ein job zug
durchzulesen und sich mit ihnen
auseinanderzusetzen
das ist natürlich irgendwie so ein traum
beispiel das kann man jetzt nicht
das lässt sich nicht verstetigen aber
ich glaube schon dass es möglichkeiten
gibt solche einladungen tatsächlich
nicht für die happy few die sowieso
schon bücher lesen und zu hause den
bücherschrank vorhaben
auszusprechen sondern dass es schon
möglichkeiten gibt
nicht nur eine einladung auszusprechen
sondern dass auch wirklich
da gemeinsam durchzugehen sozusagen in
der oberstufe oder der mittelstufe mit
dem lesen und
das ist mir auch wichtig ehrlich gesagt
dass ich nicht nur unterricht mache für
diejenigen die sowieso schon etwas damit
anfangen können sondern
ich hatte als mein debüt roman erschien
war
wenige monate später bekam ich über
instagram eine nachricht von der
schülerinnen der mein buch quasi in so
einem also jeder musste irgendwie ein
roman aus dem erscheinungsjahr quasi
gehen im deutschunterricht und danach
dann präsentieren und ihr wurde mein
buch zugelost sie hat mir dann so einen
langen brief geschrieben in dem ich
wahnsinnig gerührt hat irgendwie weil
ich jetzt einfach so nett fand dass sie
anfangen sich eben nicht gefreut hat
dass ich ein buch bekommen
das hat mich natürlich ganz besonders
berührt es war so sie schrieb dann wird
es eben gut geklappt hat und wie sie
auch im vortrag über geeignet es war
einfach sehr nett weil ich auch diesen
impuls so schön fand dass man ein buch
liest dann denkt ja jetzt erzähle ich
mal meine erfahrung mit dem buch es war
irgendwie eigentlich eine
lizensierung die mir dann tatsächlich
unterm strich für das buch am meisten
bedeutet haben weil ich das so herrlich
fand einfach diesen griff zu bekommen
wie sie dass
wir das gefallen hat und was ist mit ihr
gemacht hat das war irgendwie schön von
daher glaube ich also irgendwie passiert
ja schon was im deutschunterricht dass
die leute dann plötzlich solche
nachrichten wenn sie beim schreiben das
fand ich irgendwie toll
und ich glaube es hat auch was damit zu
tun dass da auch öffentlich die
erlaubnis war mit dem buch zu verfahren
wie man möchte was du dass es nicht eine
lösung gibt sondern ich lese das buch
und ich habe die erlaubnis
durch die türe zu betreten die mir
sinnvoll erscheint und die sachen gut zu
finden oder merkwürdig zu finden die mir
eben merkwürdig erscheinen
darum ging es ja auch vielleicht auch
das kann der distinktion spiele gespielt
werden mit den büchern da muss ich immer
daran denken ich hatte in meiner schule
ein die das lernt man ja dann auch
irgendwann in der späten mittelstufe
vermute ich dass man ja dass die aktion
über literatur gut machen also meiner in
meinem jahrgang gab es ein er hatte
immer den steppenwolf nahen landstraße
seiner sehr tief und
da muss ich immer dran denken weil ich
das so lustig finde weil das hier sinn
wahnsinnig tolles beispiel ist für buch
als distinktion und identitäts arbeit
und sich vermutlich würde heute nicht
mehr auf die art und weise funktionieren
aber ich fand es irgendwie das ist ja
auch das was man dann eben durch den
deutschunterricht lernen dass man eben
sich über ein besonders komplexes buch
was man zu seinem lieblingsbuch erklärt
auch abnehmen kann von den anderen die
zu blöd sind das zu verstehen oder so
bin das hat ja eben performativ sehr
schön umgesetzt damals ansonsten habe
ich das gefühl beim beim lesen und der
lesefreude hat auch viel einfach ja
damit zu tun dass das nicht als nur als
zwang wahrgenommen also ich kenn ich
habe ja nun drei schulkinder und wir
kriegen natürlich auch immer die
aufforderung dass sie jetzt über die
weihnachtstage dem die seitenzahl lesen
und also sehr viel was sich anfühlt wie
ihr müsst ihn jeden tag 10.000 schritte
gehen fünf sein lesen und zwei liter
wasser trinken oder es wird dann halt zu
seinem arbeit faktor die man abhakt und
das glaube ich eigentlich nicht dass das
ein besonders schöner weg ist und hab
selber gemerkt dass eigentlich das beste
für entdeckung an oder entdecken von
dieser freude jetzt sozusagen als
persönlicher erfahrung innerhalb von
meiner familie war dass man eben
langeweile entstehen last und bücher
herumliegt und irgendwann sollte es dann
halt genommen weil wir es gibt halt
gerade nichts anderes und dann muss man
halt mal und dann plötzlich steckt man
dann irgendwann magazin fast oder so
lässt durch strategisch bücher für deine
kinder rumliegen mache ich tatsächlich
das klingt jetzt sehr bürgerlich aber
das ist tatsächlich habe ich gemerkt
wenn ich bücher sozusagen gezielt danach
kaufte das kann man irgendwie
faszinierend dass ein titel der
irgendwie und die dann einfach irgendwo
hinlegen dann dauert es einfach eine
bestimmte zahl von
wochen maximal bis nicht irgendwie meine
seele der dieses buch in der hand hat
das ich platziert die eben immer so
strategisch an orten wo leute die sich
langweilen rumsitzen
soso halene oder einander auf dem auf
dem sofa tisch oder irgendwie am
küchentisch liegt hat und das
funktioniert tatsächlich erstaunlich gut
an ich möchte das jetzt kein leser
ratgeber schreiben wohl aus dieser
strategie aber die hat hier ganz gut
funktioniert tatsächlich klappt mit drei
kindern wahrscheinlich auch besser als
mit dem 1
also ich hab so was dann auch schon mal
kommentarlos offen schreibt
[Gelächter]
vielleicht noch mal an cover und titel
aber
dieses buch gut zurückgegeben habe ich
meine ich glaube auch also viele bücher
werden dann auch vielleicht nie
angefasst aber sie sind eben dann da so
und ja das denke ich auch manchmal weiß
ich also viel digital lese ich mich dann
auch schon mal gefragt was immer überall
steht in einen leser ratgebern um einen
weißen ich lese freundliche atmosphäre
muss man immer sich sozusagen permanent
zeigen dass man ein buch liest denkt ich
zeige mich ja nie dass ich ein buch lese
ich lese aber mein handy muss ich jetzt
haben strategisch nicht irgendwo
hinsetzen sind dicken hardcover und
zeigen ich lese das sozusagen als
stimmung irgendwie find ich irgendwie
auch künstlich glaube ich mach dir das
setzt ihr euch seit jahren inszenierte
euch als leben gar nicht
lesen den nachwuchs
auch wenn es an der tür klopft an die
mischmaschine ein buch entstanden
ich wollte aus einer hosentasche
ich glaube dass es dann irgendwie noch
mal eine andere stufe von von lesen ist
wenn man selbst schreibt ich würde ja
gern von berit irgendwie auch wissen
wollen wie ist das denn wenn du selbst
schreibst gibt es dann bücher die dann
gezielt ließ oder gezielt auch nicht
liest um der irgendwie entstehen nicht
zu versauen beuteln oder
liest man dann anders oder vielleicht
auch gar nicht wenn man gerade in so
einer schreib phase ist also ich weise
das ganz viele diese meinung haben dass
wenn man irgendwie was ließ was ganz
schlechten stil hat dass man dann auch
in den schlechten stil schreibt oder
sohn also dass man sozusagen
während man seinen belletristischen
roman schreibt idealerweise keine harry
potter fan fiction lesen soll oder so
habe ich jedes gar nicht so also ich
habe immer das gefühl ich das hat gar
nicht so viel einfluss darauf wie
schreibe eher so dass ich bestimmte
motive interessanten link ach das ist
irgendwie hier tolle löste tolle das
nicht lösen können also ich finde es
immer sehr also es ist ein die lesen
wenn man selber schreibt mich jetzt ist
irgendwie eine erfahrung reicher
verdeckte war so viele menschen
schreiben so toll das verunsichert mich
dann manchmal aber ansonsten
also ich finde es manchmal wenn man
besonders gute bücher dies ist dann
sozusagen schwierig diesen inneren
impuls bekommen dass man sagt ja und
mein buch sollte jetzt auch gelesen
werden weil man eben gerade ja so viele
andere tolle texte gelesen hat das
bedeutet manchmal wenn ich irgendwie das
gefühl habe ich komme nicht so gut
weiter schreiben denn je sich
tatsächlich ein bisschen weniger oder
lesen ansprache oder diese keine
deutschsprachige gegenwartsliteratur um
sozusagen diese dieses tür die tür
einfach zu zu
so dass vielleicht aber ansonsten
ist also wie ich lebe schon immer gerne
und super viel und dadurch
dass wir weiter
aber die vermeidet dann die direkte
konkurrenz nämlich die direkte sicht
weil ich das als konkurrenz wahrnehmen
sondern tatsächlich eher weil ich finde
dass es gehört ja eine gewisse form von
selbstverständnis dazu dass man sagt ja
und mein roman ist es wert irgendwie
tausend mal gedruckt zu werden und ihr
sollte den alle lesen und ich glaube da
sind wahrscheinlich menschen auch
unterschiedlich ausgestattet wie sie
sozusagen wie bereit sie sind diese
rolle am podium einzunehmen beim jesus
tatsächlich schon so dass wenn ich denke
mensch ist sind jetzt zehn bücher die
sind so super warum schreibe ich jetzt
eigentlich ein es gibt ja schon
irgendwie so viele gute bücher das ist
manchmal so da habe ich dann mit
irgendwie
und das ist natürlich keine lösen dann
so sagen ich lese jetzt einfach keine
bücher mehr weil übrigens dass keine
bücher mehr schreiben kann haben deine
kinder eigentlich deine bücher gelesen
hast du dir und strategisch rumliegt
die einzigen bücher die hier rumliegen
sind meine bücher
tatsächlich
ich mache mir da ein bisschen gedanken
über meine bücher sind ja wirklich
eigentlich nicht so
jugendfrei also ich weiß dass mein sohn
möchte gerne bin mein buch lesen das
passiert auch irgendwann sicherlich
gerade fand ist irgendwie noch ein
bisschen früh
aber es war tatsächlich so dass
natürlich über dieses gefühl dass man
mutter hat die irgendwie bücher schreibt
auch das eigene verhältnis zu büchern
sich ändern also das habe ich ganz doll
gemerkt dass sie dadurch sich mehr für
bücher interessieren auch mehr für das
eigene schreiben interessieren von
geschichten und so oder so viel also
wieviel überschreiben reden im sinne von
hass zwischen seiten hast du heute
geschrieben oder so das ist dann
irgendwie ganz nett ansonsten sieht sie
haben schon mal sachen von mir gelesen
ich habe auch schon sachen die ich nur
für sie geschrieben habe den vorgelesen
als die kleine erfahren oder aber meine
bücher sind jetzt nicht glaube ich die
beste einstieg der natur für sechs und
zehn
tage des lesens von marcel proust
geht es kurz um dante der bevor er sich
ans schreiben seiner göttlichen komödie
setzte immer ein paar seiten viel
gelesen hat um das half
oder brachte ihn in die richtige
stimmung oder irgendwie sowas aber das
ist
glaube ich dann doch das extrem es ist
tatsächlich bei mir so ich sagte sie
öfter mal das bei mir beim schreiben ist
schon so ist dass ich super hilfreich
finde wenn ich vorher ein bisschen auf
twitter lesen und dann einen tweet
schreiben weil dann hat man schon was
geschrieben und dann das ist sozusagen
dieser dieser havarie vom so nah weißen
seite im wort doch der ist dann
irgendwie das ist gebrochen indem man
eben man hat schon was geschrieben
schnell und es gewann sie okay
das ist natürlich auch ein schöner
schritt jetzt nach von von von dante und
proust so glanz und twitter
ich hätte natürlich jetzt auch mir noch
was besseres ausdenken können also eher
den steppenwolf in der hosentasche als
war es jetzt nicht eine frage hätte ich
noch habt ihr gute vorsätze fürs lesen
im nächsten jahr gibt es so was wie gute
vorsätze fürs lesen in eurem leben
überhaupt ich habe tatsächlich einen
guten vorsatz der hat auch mitlesen zu
tun aber implizit und zwar hab ich
beschlossen dass ich im nächsten jahr
ein bisschen isländische lyrik von zwei
autoren die komplett unübersetzt sind
aus spaß ins deutsche übertragen werde
also das ist ja auch eine form von
leesen
prosumer lesen also ich wollte meinen
mein guter vorsatz wissen wir ja ist
tatsächlich
dass ich ein bisschen wieder mehr
übersetzen will was ein bisschen
verschwunden ist oder zurückgetreten ist
und das gerne mitmachen möchte und bei
dir michael immer schon
lesen
ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt passt aber
ich möchte tatsächlich endlich brust
lesen
ich habe es jetzt zu einer jetzt habe
ich so eine ausgabe geschenkt gekriegt
und ich bin irgendwann mal ist man zwei
gekommen ja ich würde dass tatsächlich
gerne mal schaffen und vielleicht um
zwei ja das hängt dann von vorne an oder
siehst du bei bayern 2 weiter wo bist du
noch mal gekommen nähe ich dann kann
vorne hat es ja auch schon wieder von
vorne angefangen alles vergessen oder
das meiste vergessen und ich glaube dass
hattet ihr doch auch in eurem podcast
muss man zum schluss kommen so scheint
mir das auch man darf dann nicht
absetzen das ist sowieso gegen sind
schluckauf antrinken muss dann so
langsam anfangen und dann muss man es
durchziehen
habe ich finde die vorstellung auch ganz
schön dass es menschen gibt jedem leben
zehnmal die ersten 200 seiten gelesen
haben von dem buch aber nie weiter also
dass man im osten sagen von vorne
anfängt dann irgendwann wieder aussende
bleibt einem einfach das ist eigentlich
auch nicht schön
was menschen die das stück tragen werden
sollten seien
ja ich glaube uns bleibt der gute
vorsatz im nächsten jahr wieder lauter
wunderbare buch themen zu finden für den
podcast und wieder so machen will bücher
zu studieren daraufhin ob wir sie hier
auch für die autoren haben zum beispiel
und uns bleibt euch beiden lieberberg
liebe michael ganz herzlich für die
tolle zeit mit euch das gespräch für
eure ideen nach den eckdaten zu danken
und euch einen guten rutsch zu wünschen
in einem noch viel schöneres tolleres
2022 als das gerade vergehende ja
ohnehin schon war ja danke schön ja dann
kuscheln und einen guten wechsel ins
neue jahr
von ihnen liebe hörerinnen und hörer
wollen wir uns mit einem gedicht
verabschieden das heißt dreifachen
street journal geschrieben hat dass
georg von der front es kommt aus der
frankfurter anthologie der vorstellung
und interpretation eines gedichts die
wir seit 48 jahren jeden samstag bei uns
im tor haben und es wird vorgelesen von
thomas huber was rüdiger körner über das
gedicht schreibt finden sie in den schoß
verlinkt und auf unserer seite zeitpunkt
net / bücher - podcast bücher mit de
ganz ähnlich nämlich bücher podcast
faz.de auch hier bücher mit oui lautet
unsere e mail adresse wir freuen uns
über post
am kommenden sonntag also am 2 januar
wird paul ingendaay sich ihre bücher
podcast begrüßen da geht es dann um die
deutsche übersetzung des romans die
farbe lila und ein gespräch mit der
autorin alice walker wir beiden sind
dann am 23 januar wer physik und bevor
wir jetzt noch thomas huber mit dem
gedicht höheren wünschen wir auch ihnen
einen guten start ins neue jahr sagen
vielen dank fürs zuhören und bis bald
bis bald
georg von der fritz
dreifaches
schiff belauschte vernahm geschwür von
silben ganz undenkbar weil sie der wind
in einem ford vertauschte
so auch vertraust du der wind die
lettern in der fliegenden hallenwand und
nie gelang es zu lesen was dort rauschte
dagegen rauschte eine halten die tasten
schiffs auf dem papier grund wie fehrs
musik zu oft ich las und las
[Musik]